est ce que tu vas préparé il était
question à faire cet été doit alors que
tu as à faire cet été on va travailler
alors voir ce qu'on peut faire
oui mais sinon est ce que tu as besoin
d'un petit peu de vacances pas du tout
cinq ans manduel au boulot c'est vrai tu
vas t'ennuyer battu hier à la maison
d'accord on taviani travers un truc oui
tu te feras et moi j'irai faire durer la
piscine tu viens là d'un météorite venir
tu vas passer les vacances avec moi je
viens donc sans rigoler c'est vrai mais
par contre je peux demander que je peux
te demander juste un truc situé à la
maison quoi fourni les boissons
[Rires]
tu te situes tu mens magnon l'été non
mais j'avais prévu qu'on fasse quelque
chose pour le public mais je sais pas
quoi fâcher pas prendre de vacances
ah ouais tu veux prendre les vacances
vraiment là qu'on voit que l'émission
n'est vraiment pas préparés et non
écoute moi je suis très contente de voir
si tu veux bah on fera un truc pendant
les vacances
ouais d'accord c'est vrai mais sac de
tennis avec lui il joue bien alors alors
été détruites à la fois que j'ai fait un
tennis avec lui j'ai envoyé la balle la
balle est toujours pas passé
[Applaudissements]